great
so yeah the title of this is sketching
for linear algebra basics of
dimensionality reduction and count
sketch so I'm going to continue talking
about dimensionality reduction that Ravi
started I'm gonna focus on linear
algebraic applications like regression
low-rank approximation and variance of
these problems so the outline of the
talk is I'm first going to define the
notion of a subspace embedding in the
context of its usage for least squares
regression give different examples of
subspace embeddings they don't discuss
different ways so subspace embeddings
can be viewed as a kind of sketch of
your input or sort of dimensionality
reduction of your input and let's
describe other ways of using
dimensionality reduction in terms of
high-precision regression low-rank
approximation and I'll try to survey a
number of other problems where this
technique is useful so okay let me just
first define regression
I think Ravi already mentioned this but
I'm gonna focus on layer linear
regression which is just a statistical
method to study linear dependencies
between variables in the presence of
noise okay so here's an example Ohm's
law as the voltage is the resistance
times the current and you have a bunch
of current voltage points and you're
trying to find this unknown line which
fits them best fits them in some sense
so here's just the unknown slope or the
resistance and now there are many
different notions of what it can mean to
best fit something oftentimes there's no
line that goes through all the points I
mean you have noisy data etc okay so
just to set up some notation in the
standard setting we typically have one
measured variable B this was the voltage
on the previous slide and we have some
number of predictor variables a 1
through ad
okay so D was equal to 1 on the last
slide and a 1
with just the current and the assumption
is that these variables are linearly
related up to some noise so we have the
relationship that B is equal to some
unknown X 0 plus a 1 X 1 plus a DX D
plus some noise epsilon and so we're
trying to learn these values X I which
are sometimes called the model
parameters and we don't want to make
assumptions about this noise epsilon if
we don't have to right if we can get
more robust algorithms that work for you
know arbitrary arbitrary noise settings
this would be ideal via standard
transformation you can assume that this
X 0 term is equal to 0 so to do that
what one thing you can do is you can
replace D with D plus 1 and you can have
imagined an a0 term here which is always
equal to 1 so let's just forget about x0
and we don't just get one observation in
regression we had all these points in
the Ohm's law plot we get n observations
so let's write our problem in matrix
form so we can think of being given an N
by D matrix a the rows correspond to
examples or observations and D is the
number of unknowns we're also given this
n by 1 vector B of observations and the
regression problem just asks to find
this D dimensional vector X star so that
a times X star a is n by D so this will
be an N by 1 vector a times X star and B
are closed under some notion of
closeness okay we're going to consider
the over constrained case when there are
many more examples than unknowns ok and
it's much larger than D a is a tall thin
matrix so yeah what does it mean to you
know find the line that best fits the
data so let's first look at the least
squares method so here what you want to
do is just find this vector X so that
the Euclidean distance between a X and B
is minimized or equivalently the squared
distance
okay so this is the sum of over the
observations of what you observe - you
can think of as what you predict okay
the inner product of the I throw of a
and your chosen vector X squared okay so
this has certain desirable statistical
properties for example if this noise
epsilon being added to each of your
observations were iid Gaussian noise
then actually finding the X that
minimizes this objective function which
would give you the maximum likelihood
estimator okay
it also has a nice geometric
interpretation right so the least
squares objective function we can write
a times X as you know a linear
combination of the columns of a right so
as I range over all X I get all the Nira
combinations of the D columns of a I can
think of this as a d dimensional
subspace of R to the N so DS I'm
considering much smaller than n this is
a low dimensional subspace if R to the N
okay and and so really the problem here
of these squares regression is just to
find the point in the column span of a
which is closest to B in Euclidean norm
right so it's just the projection of B
onto the column span of a another nice
property about these squares is that
there's a nice closed form solution so
we can solve these squares via this
so-called normal equations so how to
find the solution well let's look at the
least squares objective function or
equivalently this square so let's write
our vector B of observations as a times
X prime for some X prime plus B prime
where B prime is orthogonal to the span
of the columns of a then the cost by the
Pythagorean theorem is just the squared
cost of ax minus ax prime Plus this the
squared norm of B sorry of B Prime
and so for any solution X that you might
choose you know any X you choose you're
going to pay this projection distance
the norm of B Prime
so really what you want to do is you
know just make this first term equal to
zero and so X is optimal if and only if
it satisfies the so-called normal
equations okay so what this means is so
let's look at a transpose times ax minus
B and I can substitute in this
expression that I have for B and so I'll
get ax minus a X prime minus B Prime and
we know that B prime is chosen to be
orthogonal to the columns of a so
orthogonal to the rows of a transpose so
this is just equal to a transpose times
ax minus ax prime and we know that if
we're optimal that this ax minus ax
prime this norm should be zero okay so
ax minus ax prime is zero and we get
zero and conversely if it's not zero if
ax minus ax prime is not 0 since it's
inside the column span of a you know it
has a non zero dot product with one of
the rows of a transpose and this would
be nonzero okay so the normal equation
is just that a transpose ax equals a
transpose B equipment Li you can think
of this is looking at the gradient and
sending it to be zero okay so that's the
normal equation and the nice thing is if
the columns of a are linearly
independent then I can just write down a
closed-form solution for X all right
it's a transpose a inverse times a
transpose B so the problem with this is
you know that I'll get two more is with
computation as so as Ravi was discussing
you know computing a transpose a is
expensive for large matrices
okay so naively this takes n d squared
time you can do a bit better with fast
matrix multiplication but we want to do
much faster ok just one thing to note
here is if the columns of a are not
linearly independent then there's more
than one solution there's a null space
but you can write down at least the
solution with minimum norm okay and this
is via the
so-called more penrose pseudoinverse
which I don't
which I think Robbie mentioned in a
response to a question but I don't think
it was formally defined so let me just
say it so we call the SVD that Robbie
mentioned that every matrix a can be
written as u Sigma V transpose U as
orthonormal columns Sigma is you know
now negative diagonal and I'm non
increasing as I go down and V transpose
has orthonormal rows then the more
penrose pseudoinverse a superscript this
minus is just V Sigma inverse u
transpose where what is Sigma inverse
was the diagonal matrix for the I ignore
entry is you know 1 over Sigma III if
Sigma I is better than 0 and otherwise
it's just equal to 0 ok so yeah so if
you if you write X to be the pseudo
inverse of a times B then this is a
solution with optimal costs with minimum
North ok now computing the SVD also
takes know nd squared time or you can
use fast matrix multiplication for that
as well to get a bit better but we'd
like to do a lot faster than this ok any
questions just feel free to stop me
okay yeah so the time complexity just to
put it on a slide is we need to compute
this X equals a transpose a inverse a
transpose B takes ND squared time or ND
to the one point three seven six with
fast matrix multiplication and we want a
much faster running time so this will
lead us into the technique that I
mentioned of sketching or dimensionality
reduction
okay so sketching dissolves these
squares let's first relax the problem to
allow for outputting an approximate
solution now what does that mean so
we'll look at this from an objective
function perspective so instead of
outputting the optimal vector X let's
output an X prime for which the
Euclidean distance between a X Prime and
B is at most one plus epsilon times the
optimal cost that you would get say with
the normal equations okay with high
probability so here's the sketch in
solve paradigm if you haven't seen it
before so the idea is to choose a random
matrix s from a certain family of random
matrices I'll get into different
families an important property about s
is it's very wide in fat okay so it has
a very small number K of rows typically
much less than n and no often
independent of n then the idea is to
compute s times 8 which will squash down
this tall n by d matrix into a very
small K by D matrix you can think of
this K as being roughly ordered D or D
over epsilon squared all specified more
precise than moment but roughly s times
a is a small squarish looking matrix s
times B instead of you know being n
dimensional is now only K dimensional
and now all you do is you have a black
box reduction of the original least
squares regression problem to a smaller
instance of these squares regression
where you've replaced a with s times a
and B with s times B and now you small
solve this small version of regression
which can now be solved efficiently say
with this closed form solution that I
described independent of n you know if K
does not depend on n so you can solve
this in time which is
like k times d squared if you think of K
is being roughly D this is roughly D
cube time okay so you know the goal is
to choose families of matrices s for
which this sketchin solve paradigm works
any questions yes example the
observations just picked up you know
handful of those k of those and then
solve the system this is going to be
better
what's yeah that's a good question so
the quick the question is about random
sampling can a uniformly sample a small
set of or yes so uniform sampling will
not give you the kind of relative error
that that we want you can imagine say
you know in general for regression you
can imagine you know missing a very
important example by just uniformly
sample you could think about doing
things like squared norm sampling like
Ravi was discussing but that's also not
going to give you relative error now you
can imagine something where you have a
matrix say this is your n by D n by 2
matrix and imagine all the rows have the
same norm they all look the same but for
one of the rows you have a 1 minus 1
okay and if you just sample by norms or
sample uniform you will never find this
one minus 1 but this one minus one might
be very important for fitting your data
I mean the the the the sample will have
ranked 1 versus rank two in the two
cases yeah so yeah set uniform sampling
is not going to give us a relative error
and neither will squared norm sampling
any other questions
okay okay so how to choose this matrix s
yes a lots of families of random
matrices work the first that might come
to mind is a matrix of iid normal random
variables so it turns out that if you
choose s the entries in s to be iid and
you choose each one to be a standard
Gaussian there's a scalar factor
I mean multiplied by a scalar then this
works so the sketch in Sawle paradigm
works if I choose the number of rows in
this matrix s to be order D of R epsilon
squared okay so I just replace a with s
a B with SB for this matrix S I solve
the small problem I'll get a 1 plus
epsilon approximation relative error
yeah okay let me say a little bit why
and to do so let me introduce the notion
of a subspace embedding okay so let K be
order D over epsilon squared and let s
be this matrix of iid normal random
variables so as I said they're not
standard normal the variance is 1 over K
okay this is like this 1 over root K
normalization factor that Robbie was
mentioning ok so what we'd like is the
following subspace embedding property
which is for any fixed D dimensional
subspace for example the column span of
an n by D matrix a we have the following
property for all vectors X and RD so
with high probability simultaneously for
all vectors X the Euclidean norm of s ax
is about the same as the Euclidean norm
of AX ok up to a 1 plus epsilon factor
this is the definition of a subspace in
many so notice the quantification that
it's over all vectors simultaneously now
what is the proof that a Gaussian matrix
a matrix of iid normal random variables
with this number of rows D over epsilon
squared gives you a subspace embedding
so this is via a net argument I'm going
to you know I don't have any slides on
this I'm just going to skip it but the
rough idea is to take your D dimensional
subspace the column span of a and to
discretize it with a sufficiently fine
net so to find a finite set of points
roughly 2 to the D of these points in
the subspace you find the set of points
you show that this matrix S preserves
the norm of all of those points and
since those points are sufficiently fine
for any other point in your subspace
it's close enough to one of these points
and so therefore this holds for all
vectors in your subspace that's the
rough idea
so the size of the neck can actually be
to the D you just need to choose the the
distance between the points to be
constant and then you can sort of if you
argue that for all the net points you
preserve them up to one plus Epsilon you
can do like a chaining argument like I I
preserve this I take my an arbitrary
point I write it as this point and then
I plus a difference and then I look at
the difference and I approximate the
difference with a net point as well and
I look at the difference of that
approximate with a net point and I can
do this training kind of argument so it
said so you save a log 1 over epsilon
when you do that yeah yeah any other
questions ok yeah so you know what does
this have to do with regression you know
what is the what why are we looking at
subspace embeddings yeah so this was the
definition of subspace embedding and two
for the application to regression is the
following so you know we call for
regression that we want this 1 plus
Epsilon approximate solution an
objective function value so let's just
it's a very you know direct application
consider the subspace spanned by the D
columns of a together with your vector B
it's D plus 1 dimensional instead of D
dimensional doesn't change any of the
bounds asymptotically and then just
apply this subspace embedding s to this
D plus 1 dimensional space so we'll have
that you know for all vectors why it's
norm is preserved up to 1 plus or minus
Epsilon so in particular if we look at
you know a candidate solution to the
regression problem it looks like a X
minus B you know it's inside of this D
plus 1 dimensional space that I'm
calling L and it's norm is preserved up
to 1 plus epsilon so all solutions have
their value preserved up to 1 plus
epsilon which means that I can just
solve you know this smaller version of
regression now where I've replaced a
with Si and B with SB yeah and as I said
so for normal random variable is the
number of rows of s which I was calling
K is D over epsilon squared so the time
to solve this small problem is roughly d
cubed over epsilon squared
and you can accelerate that with fast
matrix multiplication any other any
questions on this you're saying so if
for a specific as this whole and then
what are the Union changed you know yeah
so I won't address that we make no
assumptions on a you give me an eight
for any given eight I sampled this
random matrix s and I have the property
that I preserve you know the entire
subspace the entire column span of a
together with B so I preserve the entire
regression problem with some good
probability what is the probability for
the case of gaussians this can be a two
to the minus D yeah
any other questions given SA and SB so
where do we go from A and B to si
anything usually okay so this is so we
can take a we're given a and we're given
B and we just sample random Gaussian
matrix s we compute s times a and s
times B we set up this regression
problem we solve it the solution is d
dimensional and we just plug it back in
the original regression problem we save
a lot between the computer it's a great
question yeah so was that your question
- yeah perfect great you guys are both
saying the same thing yeah so this
doesn't give us a savings at all right
like I mean computing s times a you know
s has even more rows than D we already
said we could multiply by a transpose
and solve it exactly in nd square time
what are we doing now you know SSD over
epsilon squared rows it's dense
computing this product is taking even
longer than nd squared time and we're
just getting an approximate solution and
with some probability right so we we
haven't really gained anything but it's
you know sort of a proof of concept and
yeah so exactly this this this takes too
long now the first improvement to this
was given by Thomas Carlos who observed
that you can choose s instead of being
from n you know matrix with iid normal
random variables you can choose it from
a much more structured random family of
matrices called subsampled randomized
Hadamard transforms so what do these
typically look like they typically can
be factored into a product of three
matrices pH and D right and the point
about these factors is that they can all
be applied very quickly to a vector okay
so I just have one slide on this so Ken
tomorrow will elaborate more on this and
give a proof but let me just give you
some intuition so what are these factors
so D is just a random diagonal matrix so
the entries on the diagonal are chosen
independently each entry with
probability 1/2 is chosen to be one and
we probably have to chose them to be
minus one H is just the fixed matrix
they had a marred matrix so it's an
orthonormal matrix where
the entries are all bounded the nice
thing about H is it's a dense matrix but
even though it's dense there's a very
fast matrix vector product associated
with it okay which you can do
recursively it's similar to like fast
Fourier transform the entries of H
they're not so important but you know
they're all plus or minus 1 over root N
and P well P is just a sampling matrix
uniform sampling so when I apply to a
vector I just uniformly sample a subset
of coordinates in this context it's
sampling a small subset of rows of H
times D ok so D and H are both square
matrices you know they preserve the
length of an n-dimensional I mean so I
have an N dimensional vector it's still
N dimensional and P is going to the
number of rows of P tells me how many
rows I have in my sketch and the number
of rows in P can be chosen to again be
about V over epsilon squared like in the
case for gaussians but there are
additional log factors okay so
importantly s times a can be computed in
nd log n time using this fast Hadamard
transform okay the other things these
order n time P is you know even sub
linear time and you can show that this
works that if P has roughly Deever
epsilon squared rows you get a subspace
embedding and the same kind of argument
goes through and now using the
connection to regression that I
described you get a much faster
algorithm instead of nd squared you get
you know roughly nd log n yeah this can
be improved a bit using these techniques
like nd log D or so but it's you know
roughly n times D plus you know
polynomial in this small parameters like
d log n over epsilon so this is nearly
optimal in the matrix dimensions you
know it takes you sort of you have an N
by D matrix if it's dense you need to
spend nd time otherwise you'll miss say
some very large entry for example but
you know in many cases your matrix yeah
so the proof see Ken's talk in many
cases your matrix a is actually a sparse
matrix ok so you might want instead of
spending nd time to spare
time proportional to the number of
non-zeros of your input matrix a okay so
so okay so this leads to yet another
random family of sketchy matrices these
are called count sketch matrices these
make matrices are called count sketch
yeah this is originally due to Moses
Chen and frog Colton so these were these
originated in sort of a data stream
context this is why they're called count
sketch I think because kind of finding
frequent items correct me if I'm wrong
and it's also been used for things like
feature feature hashing so what are
these so these are again white fat
matrices with more rows now so instead
of just D over epsilon squared rows i
have roughly d squared over epsilon
squared rows still independent of this
large dimension n the nice thing about
these matrices s if you haven't seen
them is they're extremely sparse ok so
what they look like is they just have a
single nonzero entry per column okay so
how do i generate a matrix S for each
column I choose uniformly a position on
that position I put a 1 with probability
1/2 and the minus 1 was probably 1/2 I
can do that independently for each of
the columns but you can actually show
that bounded independence suffice is for
this as well they don't have to be fully
independent so the nice thing here is
that s times a can be computed in N and
Z of a time where N and Z is the number
of nonzero entries of a ok so why is
that I mean for each column of a for
each nonzero entry I look up the
corresponding column in s and there's
only a single nonzero entry there so I
can update my matrix matrix product in
constant time per nonzero entry ok and
the nice thing is that this this
actually works with these parameters d
squared over epsilon squared being your
number of rows and yeah so using the
connection to regression you get an
overall algorithm which runs in time
number of nonzero entries of a plus a
polynomial in
over epsilon so I'm going to focus on
this one and give you a a proof of why
this one works the other two families of
matrices I didn't give proofs for any
questions so far
yes this works with uh I thought maybe
and I would assume that would be um one
- Victor right yeah so four count sketch
the property is not very high like what
we'll see is they'll be a linear
dependence on Delta here yeah unlike for
gaussians where we had sort of
exponential okay okay so here's a simple
proof so yeah
due to in in a paper of everyone knew in
and I so what we what we had is what we
want to do is show the following we'd
like to show that the the norm of si X
is 1 plus or minus epsilon the norm of
AX for all X we just have the subspace
embedding property we like this show the
first observation is you can assume that
the the columns of a or orthonormal now
why is that well you're going to be
proving this statement for all vectors X
right so as I range over all X you know
I'm ranging over all ax
I'm ranging over all vectors in my
column space it doesn't really matter
which basis I range over so I might as
well range over a basis where a has
orthonormal columns okay there's the
first observation the second observation
is that this is a linear map right so I
might as well just prove this statement
for unit vectors X if I prove it for all
unit vectors x and therefore ax is also
a unit vector since a has orthonormal
columns then it holds for all X by
linearity so really I just need to prove
that the norm of s ax is 1 plus or minus
epsilon for all unit X and again after
we've shown a subspace embedding
guaranteed then we immediately get the
application to regression just by
applying it to a comma B okay so here's
the the argument
so let me instantiate the number of rows
of s to be 6 d squared over Delta
epsilon squared as I said it's roughly D
over ups a d squared over epsilon
squared ok so here is the sort of a key
observation
let's look at the operator norm of a
transpose s transpose si minus the
identity okay this is a D by D matrix
this is a D by D identity and suppose
just ignore this middle norm suppose we
show that this operator norm is at most
Epsilon then we're all set right why is
that
because then if I apply si to any vector
X do I apply it X transpose X and the
unit vector then this will become the
norm of SI x squared X transpose X
that's just going to become one it's a
unit vector and so I'm saying the norm
of SI x squared minus one is at most
Epsilon
that's the same thing as saying that you
know for all vectors X the norm of Si X
is 1 plus or minus Epsilon okay so this
operator norm captures you know sort of
all vectors that clear okay so it's hard
to bound and operate a norm directly so
instead of bounding the opportun or I'm
gonna upper bound the operator norm by
the Frobenius norm and I'm said I'm just
going to show that the Frobenius norm of
a transpose s transpose si minus the
identity is at most Epsilon remember
Frobenius norm just sum of squares of
entries to the one half for being a
storm is something that I understand
much better right just sum of squares of
entries so you know we have a form for s
we can imagine just trying to compute
this directly and that's what we do okay
so what we will show below is that the
maker the following matrix product
result which is that you give me any two
fixed matrices C and D if I sample one
of these random count sketch matrices s
then I can approximate the matrix
product C times D so suppose you know C
the number of columns of C is the same
as the number of rows of D so that these
can be multiplied instead of computing C
times D I'm going to compute C times s
transpose times s times D and what I'd
like is this matrix product result which
is that the norm of the difference of my
approximation in the actual product or
the squared norm
at most you know something that's you
know roughly one over the number of rows
of my sketch s times the squared for
brainiest norm of c times the squared
for being a storm of d with some good
probability okay so it's sort of the you
know my approximation is getting better
as i increase my number of rows of my
skeptic matrix and it's going down sort
of the error is going down linearly on
that yeah so any any questions about
this so this is what we're going to show
but i just want to say that once we have
this property this approximate matrix
product we immediately get a proof of
this statement this subspace embedding
which I'll just give on the next line
okay so here's the proof so all we do is
if we have this matrix product result
set C to be a transpose and D to be a I
remember a has orthonormal columns so
what is C times D it's just the identity
and you know what do we get we get a
transpose s transpose s times a minus
the identity Frobenius norm squared is
it most something that's exactly you
know of the form that we would like to
show a subspace embedding and so how
many the question is just how many rows
of s do I need to choose well what is
the squared for vinius norm of a well
it's a matrix with orthonormal columns
right it has d columns so the squared
four be nice form of that matrix is d
the squared four be no storm of d which
is just a transpose is also d so I get a
d squared here and I just need to set my
number of rows to be roughly d squared
to cancel this d squared okay so more
precisely if I set my number of rows to
be six d squared over Delta epsilon
squared these D Squared's cancel this
Delta cancels and I'm left with an
epsilon squared here and after taking
square roots I get back this epsilon
that I that I asked for yeah question no
so actually for the count sketch matrix
d squared is actually tight one way to
look at that is to look at the identity
matrix so one way of viewing the count
sketch matrix is hashing rows into
buckets and if you have fewer than d
squared rows in your sketch then you'll
get a collision and so your rank will go
down from D to something like D minus 1
so it can't be a subspace embedding so
actually this turns out to be a tight
analysis for count sketch but you can
apply the same analysis to those earlier
sketching matrices like gaussians and
subsample randomized Hadamard and for
those it's not tight as we saw yeah
other questions yeah anything with more
than a square also work thank your
computation yeah you can use more than d
squared here yeah it's yeah it's still
like nuns n NZ of a number of nonzero
entries of a time to reduce it to this
problem and then now note if you use
more rows you have to spend more time on
the smaller problem and by the way one
other thing I did want to mention is
that going back to Fred's question is
you can get better bounds so if you have
some assumptions on a for example if the
so called leverage scores which we'll
see later in this workshop if they're
all small inside of your matrix a then
actually count sketch can this can be
shown to work with only roughly DeRose
yeah but under no assumptions this is
tight yeah question so in general you're
saying that this cup of this extra
factor of T is necessary if you want to
have a sparse matrix sort of bound
guarantee of n n CLA like a what like
for accounts cash for one sparse yeah so
there are very nice trade-offs of Nelson
and New Eden which showed a trade-off
between the sparsity and like the number
of nonzero entries in each column of s
and the the number of rows you need in
your sketchy matrix so if I allow for
like a hundred nonzero entries per
column of s then I can reduce you know
the number of rows of s times a to
something like D to the one point one in
general like if I allow like poly log D
I can reduce this down to d poly log D
rows
I think the latest result is due to
Michael Cohen on this yet
any questions
okay okay so you know it remains to
complete this proof to give this matrix
product result you know I just sort of
claim this so why is it true yeah we
want to show that the squared norm of C
s transpose s D minus C D is small okay
so to prove this so there many ways of
proving this we're going to do a very
slick way do to Cain and Nelson which is
the following let's say a distribution
on matrices s has the JL property
Johnson installs property more precisely
has the epsilon Delta L JL moment
property if for any given vector X with
unit norm we have the following bound
that the expectation over a random
matrix s from this distribution of the
elf moment of the squared norm of s X
minus 1 is at most epsilon to the L
times delta ok so this is giving us some
control over the higher order moments of
you know length preservation so you know
similar to so Ravi was talking about
some of this earlier so yeah so it has
epsilon Delta L there moment property at
the elf moment of s x squared minus 1
this is small and so this is just a
statement about distributions of
matrices applied to vectors X and we'd
like to go from the statement to this
approximate matrix product statement
that I did that I said so the the
transition is the following so let D be
a distribution on matrices s with K rows
and n columns that has the epsilon Delta
L JL moment property for some L at least
two then for any fixed matrices a and B
with n rows so you can multiply them you
get this approximate matrix product
guarantee that namely the probability
over s that the norm of your approximate
matrix product a transpose s transpose s
B minus a transpose B there probably
that it's large
is small okay so it's the same number of
roads that you use in your Jo moment
property and you just directly apply it
to matrices and you get the statement
about matrices yeah yeah these are the
same statement I've just written it
slightly differently here so if you
rearrange things here you know put less
than here put greater than 1 minus Delta
etc you'll get back the same statement
yeah I'll mention that more later yeah
any other questions that you started
with B is a so it's more structures
could we do I mean oh can you do better
if like a and B or equal yeah I don't
think so
I mean not asymptotically because you
can kind of yeah I mean maybe look at a
block matrix where a is inside and B is
inside and so I'm not sure I don't think
you can you can't do better
asymptotically you might be able to do
better in constant factors yeah
any other questions okay will be another
this treatment there we both inner
products of uneconomic producing from
vectors - yeah so this you know this
product is really a collection of inner
products you know between the rows of a
transpose and and B and the columns of B
and that's you know how we're going to
prove this so yeah that's a different
way of saying
okay so let's try to prove you know
first we're going to prove this
transition statement that from we get
this result from vectors and matrices
and then we'll show later that the count
sketch matrix has the JL moment property
okay so how do we prove this okay so
let's set up some notation for a random
variable X a scalar random variable
let's define the P norm I didn't I
didn't say why it's a norm yet the P
norm of X to be the expectation of the
absolute value of x to the P raised to
the 1 over P and you know how are we
going to apply this well in our proof
sometimes this scalar X will be the
Frobenius norm of a random matrix T for
example okay so right so and then you
would just get that the P norm of the
Frobenius norm of T is the expected
value of the Frobenius norm of T to the
P raised to the 1 over P okay now you
can show that this P norm is actually a
norm for any P at least one okay so it
you know it's zero at zero the main
thing to show here is the triangle
inequality and the triangle inequality
turns out just to be Minkowski
inequality okay
that the the P noam of X plus y is at
most the peano of X plus the p-norm of
why this is Minkowski inequality and it
basically comes down to holders
inequality in the proof but I won't I
won't prove that here okay so all right
so let's let's look at unit vectors x
and y and let's bound the l norm of the
difference in inner products between the
sketch you know sx sy that inner product
and the actual inner product XY okay so
this will be a useful primitive to have
okay so let's just write out an
expression for this difference well one
way of writing this is I claim is the
following so it's 1/2 times the squared
norm of s X minus 1 plus the squared
norm of sy minus 1
- the squared norm of X minus y minus
the squared norm of X minus y what's
going on here all that's going on here
is I'm taking you know one of these
expressions and I'm just expanding it
okay so the squared norm of s X of s
times X minus y is the squared norm of
SX plus the squared norm of s y minus
twice the inner product of SX and sy all
right that's all that's happening so the
squared norm of SX here will cancel this
squared number of SX the squared norm of
sy will cancel this squared norm of sy
and I also do the expansion for the
squared norm of X minus y so I'll get
squared norm of X plus square norm of Y
minus twice the inner product of x and y
these are unit vectors so the square
norm of X the squared norm of Y those
are both 1 those will cancel these ones
and so I'll get twice this difference
and I have a 1/2 in front okay so that
that's all I've done okay now I'm
looking at the El norm of this quantity
and what do we know about the El norm
well we know it's a norm so in
particular I can apply the triangle
inequality so this is at most 1/2 times
the El norm of you know SX squared minus
1 plus the Ella norm of s Y squared
minus 1 plus the yelled norm of X minus
y squared minus X minus 1 is with me
okay okay and what do we know about each
of these things here
remember this transition statement we're
trying to prove if s has the je a moment
property then it satisfies something
about approximate tricks product so what
is the jail moment property tell us
I mean it tells us how to bound each one
of these terms right X is a unit vector
Y is the unit vector X minus y is on the
unit vector but I can just you know
factor out the norm of X minus y so just
directly applying the day a moment
property I get that this L norm is at
most epsilon times Delta to the one over
L this L norm is at most epsilon times
Delta the 1 over L and the last thing I
get its at most the norm of X minus y
squared times epsilon to the Delta times
epsilon times Delta to the 1 over L ok
now the norm of X minus y squared you
know is that most for x and y are unit
vectors so this is at most say 3 times
epsilon times Delta to the 1 over L ok
so this is just some statement about
differences of inner products so by
linearity this was for unit vectors but
for the by the narrative for arbitrary x
and y we get the same statement right so
I can divide out by the norm of X and
the norm of Y and I get that for
arbitrary x and y you know this inner
product divided by the norms now is it
most say three epsilon Delta to the 1
over L ok clear
okay good so now what why are we doing
this so ultimately we want to say
something about matrix product so now
let's look at a matrix product and as
Dara I mentioned this basically boils
down to a bunch of inner products so let
the columns of a be a 1 through ad and
that the columns of B be B 1 through B e
say let's define X IJ to be the
following quantity it's 1 over the norm
of AI times the norm of B J times the
difference of you know s AI inner part s
PJ minus AI inner product BJ why do we
do that well that's exactly the entry in
the matrix product a transpose B ok so
what do we have here we have that this
squared norm of this approximately Twix
product that we care about is equal to
the sum over all entries I and J of X IJ
squared times the squared norm of AI
times a square norm of B J ok so that
was the point of setting it up like this
is that clear
really ok ok so now we just want to
bound this quantity
let's do that okay good so so what have
we shown so far we've just shown this
statement for arbitrary vectors x and y
you know we have some bound on the
difference of inner products over the
norms and we've also set up this
notation for these X I gaze and we
showed our matrix product can be written
in terms of those X IJ's okay so let's
look at the following quantity and it'll
be clear why we're looking at this in a
second so I want to look at a norm you
know so I'm gonna look at the L over two
norm of the Frobenius norm or rather
squared Frobenius norm of this matrix a
transpose s transpose SP minus a
transpose B and we just said that we can
write this matrix using this expression
in terms of the X IJ s okay so that's
all I've done there I just substituted
in the definition okay so what can we do
with this expression
that's people with me
what should the first thing and what
what is one thing we can do with this
this expression so it's the L of our 2
norm of the sum of a bunch of stuff try
anybody call you great thank you so by
triangle inequality this is at most the
sum you know of the norms of all that
stuff
so the sum over all I and J squared norm
of AI squared oma be J times the L over
2 norm of X IJ squared right that's the
only random variable there these other
things are just scalars ok ok ok so now
this next line all I'm doing is I'm
playing with the definition of the L
over 2 norm remember the yell over to
norm of some quantity is like that
quantity to the L over 2 you know the
expectation of that quantity the
expectation of the absolute dog of that
quantity to the L over 2 raised to the 2
over L so this is just a definitional
statement right because when I raise X
I'd a squared to the L over 2 I get X IJ
to the L to the 2 over L that's the same
thing that's going on here it's just a
definitional statement
okay now what do we know from you know
the statement that we have up here
well the Exide gays have this form and
this form is exactly what we know we can
apply this jail moment property to right
I mean if I look at what the X IJ is
they have the form of a of a difference
of inner products and I'm normalizing by
the norms that's exactly what we can
apply this statement that we had for
arbitrary vectors x and y so just
plugging in that statement we upper
bound this squared L norm as as this
value squared okay and I just factored
that out and inside I have you know the
sum of squares of you know a I squared
sum over all I J of norm of AI squared
oh my be J squared and what is this
quantity
yeah it's just a product of Frobenius
norm squared for being a storm's so this
is just three epsilon Delta to the 1
over l squared times the product gets
squared for being in stores
okay we're almost done we'll finish on
this slide okay so why did we look at
this quantity well we're just going to
apply Markov bound on a higher order
moment just like Ravi did in his talk so
let's look at the expected value of the
you know elf power of the Frobenius norm
of our approximate matrix product a
transpose s transpose s B minus a
transpose B okay the claim is that this
is just equal to this expression that we
had up here raised to the L over tooth
power
okay that's again just a definitional
statement okay
so like what is the L over two norm of
this well it's the expected value of
this raised to the L over two so I'll
get the elf power here which is exactly
what's over here
all raised to the 2 over L and that will
cancel this L over two okay it's just a
definitional statement okay but we just
bounded this quantity here so now we're
gonna apply Markov's inequality and
complete the proof so the probability
that the Frobenius norm of our
difference exceeds some amount well I
can raise both sides to the elf power
right so I raised this side to the elf
power I raised this side to the elf
power and then I just apply Markov bound
so it's at most you know the expectation
of this quantity divided by this
quantity to the elf power so I get
exactly this this this expression and
finally you know I just plug in the
bound that we just proved for this
expectation so we just showed that this
expectation here is this quantity which
is the L over toothpowder of this
quantity
right so you know so what happens here I
raise this quantity to the L over 2
let's this look at epsilon for example
so I get epsilon squared to the L over 2
I get epsilon to the L that cancels this
epsilon to the L you know I get 3 to the
L that cancels this 3 to the L etc right
I get for being a storm of a to the L
this is being raised to the L over 2
cancels for penis no more of a to the L
all that stuff cancels I'm just left
with Delta that's the whole argument
okay so we showed that if we have the
Dale property for vectors then we get
the approximate matrix product property
that we wanted so yeah so just recall
this is the approximate to expect
property that we wanted we started
assuming that our matrix s is drawn from
a distribution which has this JL moment
property and we said well if we take the
same matrix s with the same number of
rows then it satisfies this approximate
matrix product property yeah question so
okay so we're going to show that this
holds for l equals 2 you have to show it
for some L at these two we're going to
show this holds for l equals 2 yeah yeah
this this is all all we're going to use
so I think Jeremy Epson you have some
work on this recently with Cowan and
Devon
using other values of L for these kinds
of proofs linear in 1 over 10 yeah even
the territory
right you don't need iron yeah I mean so
for us we're just going to get like one
of our Delta dependents this is all
that's going to matter and we're not
going to use this kind of proof for the
other families and matrices okay yeah
okay so we just need to show to wrap up
the proof that count sketch works for
regression that it satisfies the JL
property and bound the number K of rows
as it has oh yeah
oh let's see do we actually need this to
be the most half I don't think this is I
think this is arbitrary yeah similar
they might have been hiding some
constants but yeah
any other questions
okay okay so counts get satisfies the
jail property this is just a you know a
statement about applying count sketch to
a vector you know we want to bound we're
gonna prove this for l equals two so we
just want to bound the expected value
you know of the square number of s X
minus 1 squared and this really can't be
that hard right I mean this is just so
let's just go through this very quickly
so let's first is considered the
expectation of the square norm of SX is
it unbiased so we want this to be one
right so a four-count sketch matrix s is
convenient to parameterize it in terms
of two things one is a hash function H
which specifies for each column where
the nonzero entry is okay so it's a hash
function from the end columns to the K
rows tell me where each nonzero entry is
and there's also a sine function so for
each column the sine function Sigma
tells me the value on that nonzero entry
is it 1 or is it minus 1 ok and let's
just let Delta e be 1 if some probably
stick event a holds otherwise Delta V is
equal to 0 and let's just compute this
expectation okay it's very
straightforward so the expected squared
norm of SX what's the sum over the K
coordinates of SX of the squared value
on that on the coordinates so what is
the squared value on the coordinate well
it's the sum over all indices I between
1 and n first I need an event that
actually the the I column had its
nonzero entry in the J throw so that
there's an indicator that that happened
if it did happen then I multiplied by
the sine associated with that nonzero
entry Sigma I times the actual value X I
this is I'm computing the square norm
I'm taking the square of this
everybody okay so let's just expand the
square on the next line so all I did now
is i expanded this and I have a sum over
all pairs of indices i1 and i2 between 1
& M and now I have this expectation you
know of the product you know I have 2 of
these things now so indicator that the I
want coordinate hashes to the date
bucket and the eye tooth coordinate
hashes to the date bucket times Sigma AI
1 Sigma 2 times x i1 x i2 where I'm
calling the Rose buckets this is just
expanding the squared and now there's
some observation here so suppose that I
1 is not equal to I 2 then what is the
expectation of this quantity here 0
right because these are random signs I 1
is not equal to I 2 this is at least
pairwise independent the expectation is
0 so instead you just get a sum over all
indices I of the expectation that this
indicator is squared you know that the I
entry gets hashed to the J's bucket
times X I squared what is the
expectation of this well what is this
expectation
it's just the probability that the ice
coordinate you know the eye column has
its nonzero entry in the Jayce row what
is that probability just one over K the
number of rows right so this is 1 over K
and I'm summing up over K things each
one of them I'm getting the sum of
squares of all the entries so I get an
unbiased estimator right the squared
norm of SX is the squared norm of X ok
so ok so so it's three o'clock now yeah
why don't we take a break for half an
hour and I'll you know when we come back
we'll conclude with showing that count
sketch has the data moment property and
then we'll start looking at other
problems
[Applause]